does uh sleep terrify you guys what the
[__] is this I've been I've just had
this like realization okay
what happened some sometimes I go into
like God mode in the shower and I'm like
and I have this existential thought that
just [__] hits me and I'm like okay
I'm terrified of something new now great
why are you terrified of sleeping that
because okay what is the difference many
times what is the difference between
sleeping and dying tell me that tell me
that uh wow you dream when you sleep uh
you're not dead that's the biggest aside
from that but but from your own
perspective you wake back up no there is
there's no difference
I think I thought about this because I
was like what I always fall into like
random Youtube holes and I was just like
random facts people don't know how
anesthesia really works but it just does
for some reason right what do you mean
like in terms of like you know when you
go under for surgery yeah like they
still do not like know on a molecular
level why like anesthesia works why it
knocks you out yeah but then now I'm
afraid to take an estate
well I don't know
how but it seems to be weird
so I would just take it if I was you
it'd save my kids yeah because I've
luckily luckily I've never needed like
surgery or anything like that so I've
never needed to go under
um so I don't know I don't know I don't
know what it's like I have any of you
guys needed to take anesthesia or
anything like that I think do I ever go
to the hospital I need to get anything
serious done he's like man we gotta
stitch up your finger man just put me
under just just [__] knock me out I
do not want to be work for any of this
yeah I'm totally fine with you opening
me up while I'm asleep I just don't want
to know every every time they take blood
from you they just like pull me on the
door
blood's probably like my my like it's
getting closer to my limit of like man I
don't want to do this yeah I'll do it
yeah I I didn't realize before but I
think I just I don't know I don't think
I have a fear of getting my blood taken
but I think I'd like to know when I'm
getting my blood taken beforehand so I
can have you ever had your blood taken
without you knowing no not without my
nails no no
but uh actually today I did have an
appointment yeah uh and I did need to
get my blood taken oh and I didn't know
that I needed to get my blood taken oh
you thought you felt uncomfortable you
turned up and yeah oh you want to know
beforehand yeah yeah so normally we
would normally when I go to the doctor
or when we have a health checkup I'm
like okay I'm getting my blood taken I
can mentally prepare myself I know this
is going to happen so I go to this
appointment and they're like okay uh we
probably need to just do a quick check
of your blood uh before anything else as
well since it's been a while and I'm
like
sorry what wait so how much notice do
you need then how much notice yeah how
much notice I gotta give you before I
take your blood
you gotta you gotta put in like a notice
is it like just a One Wing thing yeah
one day thing just just when I turn up
to the building for an appointment you
just want to check up I just want to
know before so I can just be like okay
I'm getting my blood taken today and
here's the thing I don't know why I
never used to think about this I know
before I'd be like getting blood taken
whatever but yeah the more the time has
gone on for some reason I don't know if
it is being around Sydney because Sydney
has Sydney is deathly afraid of needles
um and I think being around her and her
fear of needles some of that fear might
have like gotten pushed onto me
subconsciously I have no idea is it
because you've seen like Sydney's blood
getting taken a lot where you're just
like oh that thing looks uh I think so
actually yeah because I remember one
time I had to like literally the first
time Sydney going I don't know if I've
ever told this story on the podcast
maybe I have but first time she got ill
um had to take her to the hospital
uh because she had a very very bad fever
um of course uh she had to get blood
taken
um and like I guess like me now if she
gets blood taken she needs not a day she
needs like a [__] week or month
notice to be like I'm building up to
this one moment doctor goes okay we need
to take your blood and uh I had to
literally help the nurses hold her down
while uh while we we take her Jesus
Christ
run away she was that she was like that
afraid of needles to be fair she's she's
gone a lot better now
um but I think I think that one time
when I because normally when I get blood
taken I never look at the blood being
taken and I think that I think having
now helping Cindy every time calm down
whenever she gets her blood taken every
time I see like her blood getting taken
I'm like that looks that doesn't look
natural man something's wrong that was
in her body that was in her body I think
watching someone else get that butt
taken I'm kind of like yeah but then
when I watched it happening to me I'm
like whoa that's weird I love seeing my
blood getting taken you're a freak
you're a freak I'm just like look how
much it's gushing I remember because um
I uh I had to get blood tests all the
[__] time
um because uh I've just got diagnosed
with hemophilia which is a genetic thing
um not genetic hereditary yeah
um and I remember they used to take my
blood all the time and dude to the
stairs don't want this toy they have
this thing and it was like it was like a
like four cubes by four cubes and they
had like the floating ink in water yeah
like a lava lamp right right more
viscous yeah and it was just like a
house where like all the ink would just
go around and it would Spin and do
anything I thought that was [__] was so
cool and they would just show it to you
just like oh
fluid thing or what yeah like a
ferrofluid kind of thing and just kind
of like it would just go around the
house and do a bunch of obstacles and
yeah I just want that as a thing now it
was cool to look at I was like wow oh my
blood's gone
have any of you guys ever needed to take
like any strong like painkillers like
morphine or anything along those
anything on those levels uh no I don't
think so I mean like it's copia yes you
just cope every morning like like I
don't know I've never had to go to like
the hospital for any kind of like major
injury yeah at least from what I
remember no wisdom teeth getting taken
out or anything like that I still have
all my wisdom teeth uh they came out
straight which is great
um I don't know I don't know yeah I've
never been like I've always been curious
about what it feels like to get to that
state of mind because you know you
sometimes you see videos of people
taking their wisdom teeth out and they
just it looks funny it does look
hilarious at the same time I would be
deathly terrified uh if that ever
happened to me because I have no doubt
that if you boys took me to the get my
wisdom teeth out you just take advantage
of my mental state I think you have to
film it like I think of course
we need to do a trash Case episode with
you just like
you film it and then if it's too cringe
you delete and if it's funny oh great we
keep it yeah you know it's just uh it's
like uh those weird videos it's just
real life yeah
yeah
yeah yeah I think the only time I've
seen someone like that happened to
someone was another time I had to take
Sydney to the hospital God so it's just
your experiment yeah
even four cc's of morph
she wasn't actually limit testing yeah
exactly she wasn't given morphine but
she was given another strong painkiller
at the hospital it was in America and I
remember she was uh she was in pain and
then she wasn't in pain and it was like
oh it's all good and she was very clear
in the mind she was acting like normal
Sydney and then she just goes to me so
God like
serious question
are those walls moving and I'm like no
those walls are not moving she was like
Peter when the wars move did the doctor
give a shrooms I I
almost straight voice he was like no I
think those walls are moving and you are
can we can we get out of this room
please
why are the walls wiggling right what if
you went back and pushed the wall
you went up to it and then maybe I would
be I would be wiggling yeah yeah yeah
yeah just to [__] with her
yeah I mean it's it does scare me
sometimes how easy it is to like
manipulate the mind you know [__] was
you saying it that in that Blazer
so like so I heard you want to be
manipulated yes
uh the only um actually I don't know I
don't know the ending to this story
um when I was really young you know
those um those those I don't know what
they are they're like they're like
balloons things but they have weights at
the bottom so you punch it yeah it goes
back down and then it comes right back
up I don't know if I've told the story
before like the punching bag yeah yeah
kind of a punching bag but for kids it's
kind of like you know I don't like this
big and um I was just punch in mine and
I was punching I was having a good time
and then I don't know how this happened
my brother starts screaming he's like ah
I'm like what's wrong he's like your
thumb my thumb is just backwards like
down here yeah
I have this memory of looking at it
going
because I'm just like what the [__] but
I couldn't feel anything I remember not
being able to feel it at all did you
like dislocating so yeah and I don't
remember I don't know I think I fainted
or passed out and then wait hold on you
you dislocated your thumb on a [__]
balloon yeah on a balloon and then I and
then I woke back up and I remember
everything just being okay how weak are
your joints I know right I have like an
80 year old man's joint sorry I don't
know how that happened I must have just
like hit it in some way I don't know
Jesus it was a funny story man my mum
loves telling me that story okay so like
because I've always wondered right like
when when you see like people like
dislocate a joint right yeah I've always
wanted
do you feel that like does it hurt
absolutely right it must do right I
don't know because I feel like I've
been more dislocator the more it can
happen again right and I think the more
that maybe it might not hurt but more
you get used to the sensation right